- You can live on six hours sleep.
So, you have 18 hours.
You have 18 God damn hours.
I wanna know what you're
doing with your 18 hours.
Because you can work your
nine to five, and that's nine.
And you can travel for an
hour here and there, respect.
Nice little solid commute.
Oh, you wanna be a family man?
Masel tav, you can spent
two hours with your kids.
What are you doing with
those other five hours?
You're watching House of fucking Cards.
You're playing Madden.
You're relaxing from the other intense 10.
Gary, I already spent 11 hours.
Well great, then don't
complain or want more.
Respect that by getting
rest and this and that
you're giving up opportunity
to go into a new world.
You want the audacity to
have a one percent life.
And let's call it what it is.
You want to live as well
as the one to two percent
in the world.
It's not very complicated,
the math is very raw.
If you want to have one of
the best lifes in the world,
which is you live on your terms,
you have to pay your dues to get there.
And you have to be lucky
enough to figure out
that you had talent in the thing
that you actually wanna do.
Because you can work 24 hours a day,
and if you stink at golf,
or you're not a good content producer,
or your logos look like
the shit I would make,
then you're gonna lose.
So, that's what you gotta do.
♪ Good bye ♪
♪ Bye ♪
♪ Goodbye ♪